course the world is watching so let's
bring in chief foreign affairs
correspondent and face the nation
moderator margaret brennan who joins us
now margaret good morning the president
seemed to spend a portion of his speech
yesterday arguing to americans that
there is value in the u.s engaging more
with the world so let's get into the
details a little bit what stood out to
you about the president's message on
foreign policy
well good morning to you tony that
phrase relentless diplomacy stood out
because the administration isn't
practicing relentless diplomacy at the
moment so this is very aspirational un
addresses often are but this seemed to
gloss over some of the complexities that
the biden administration is facing
their diplomatic overtures to broker a
transition of power in afghanistan for
example fell apart
and allies said they weren't even fully
consulted the diplomacy with iran over
its nuclear program is stalling and
these attempts to broker a climate deal
with china have largely failed that's
not my analysis that is what the
secretary general of the united nations
said on sunday so this has been a really
tough start for the diplomacy here and
the president made clear he is a very
strong aversion to military force and
wants to try to avoid conflict with
china so the diplomacy may be more
focused there
yeah a lot of world leaders have
criticized the american pull out from
afghanistan at least the chaos that
remain you spoke recently to president
erdogan of turkey who's facing an afghan
refugee crisis at his borders what did
he tell you
this was an exclusive interview and
erdogan came with a message that he is
very frustrated to inherit the
consequences of u.s action abroad
including the chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan his country has the most
refugees in the world and now they have
a wave of afghans headed towards their
border i asked him what should be done
you said last month turkey has no duty
responsibility or obligation to be a
refugee warehouse whose obligation is it
is it america's obligation to take in
these refugees
right now the united states
failed to
meet
its obligations
we have more than 300 000 afghan
refugees and we will no longer be able
to afford to welcome any more afghan
refugees in turkey does the us need to
do more
yeah
of course the united states
should do a lot and should invest a lot
because
the united states has been there for the
last 20 years but why
why
first these questions should be answered
by the united states
should the u.s do more margaret and he
he hedged a little bit in his answer he
didn't didn't come out with a clear yes
what did you make of it
well it further on in the interview he
he did say you know more needs to be
done here and and really
he's looking for some support from the
rest of the international community but
he's building a wall literally to try to
keep afghan refugees out at the moment
but the pressure here is back on the
administration which has up the number
of refugees it will accept to this goal
of 125 000
but there is frustration from those in
the neighborhood that they have been
left to pick up the pieces and they
would like uh something more from the
united states i suspect that means more
financial aid and more support when it
comes to
dealing with the fallout from the
withdrawal in afghanistan so this is
something we're going to watch turkey is
also one of the
few countries that is being turned to by
the united states to be a lifeline to
the taliban and perhaps help uh
keep an idea of how to stabilize the
country through them
yeah indeed margaret thank you very much
and this sunday on face the nation
you'll be
able to see more of margaret's interview
with turkey's president erdogan as they
discuss human rights and america's role
on the world stage during the biden
presidency we